yeah i don't know i
uh
um
you you calling out to the crew and
that's not a good idea letting them know
that you need a moment reminds me of one
of my early experiences with one of the
worst directors i was working on this
movie
that uh it was it was my first big role
in an independent feature this was
almost 20 years ago
and the director was he really didn't
know what he was doing but he thought
that he was scorsese and
it was my first day on set
and uh
and he
and we did one take
and he comes up to me and he he had this
really kind of creepy way of of talking
to actors which is he would he would
whisper
conspiratorially in your ear as if what
he was saying was shameful
and so he comes up to me and he says ah
um misha um
are you all right you seem a little
uh
and i was like
what what
you don't say that too like after the
first take on my first day on set so i
and now i'm thinking oh god why i've com
like i'm they're gonna fire me
this is horrible who is this guy and uh
and he says and i say yeah i think i'm
okay and he's like looks at me sort of
side eye like are you sure and i said
yeah and he said okay okay all right
everyone we're going again and i said
wait wait um larry can you just i'm
sorry can you give me one second and he
said sure
and then he screams
everyone quiet on the set misha needs a
minute
this is the worst director in the
history of director it was this
cavalcade of
bad directing uh this probably made you
freak out even more of course it did yes
so there i was in the middle of my first
scene on having a little bit of first
day having a panic attack that was quite
in due in large part to the director's
bad direction
do you ever have days where you feel
like an amateur like you can't get your
lines out you can't you you the nerves
start happening you've done this a
million times but all of a sudden you're
like why am i feeling this and you feel
like you're a newbie again and you just
want to take off to the moon or
something for some reason for me that
happens pretty much
every time i'm on